attention c'est parti pour dix secondes
que vous pouvez scrollé si vous n'en
avez rien à faire de mes spectacles je
suis le 24 novembre dédicace à colmar
puis en spectacle dans la belgique le 29
novembre à namur le 30 amont et le 1er
décembre à louvain la neuve
ensuite en suisse mais c'est déjà
complet annoncé déjà complet à mulhouse
le 11 décembre le 15 décembre hier et le
31 décembre à paris et ensuite 40 dates
l'année prochaine en 2020 bien tous
saluent le lien dans la description jeu
peu après avoir ce qu'elle est dans
l'eau est choqué c'est comme dans comme
un peu le fait que je ne regarde pas il
ya que les douleurs du bois salue
aujourd'hui pour une fois c'est pas moi
qui vais proposer un casse tête ou qui
fait fabriquer une énigme pour quelqu'un
d'autre
on m'a fabriqué une espèce de chasse au
trésor qui ici sur ce bureau et je vais
devoir résoudre alors on va commencer
dans quelques secondes parce qu'il ya
déjà des objets qui m'intrigue jus ce
qui m'a fait ça est ce que vous vous
souvenez de trésors perdus c'est une
vidéo dont je vous ai parlé en 2007 que
je vous ai faite en 2007 où je vous
parlais d'un livre qui permettait de
gagner un trésor etc
et moi avec le même maison d'édition
l'année dernière j'ai fait la recherche
d'aidés diamant perdus volés perdu volé
parce que je connais bien le nom de mes
livres c'est important de savoir lady
diamants ont été retrouvées gagner je
vous ferai une vidéo sur ce sujet sur la
chaîne secondaire mais du coup heureux
lance un projet cette année qui
s'appelle l'ordre de sipan ayez une
statuette qu'ils ont fait fabriquer au
pérou qui en or avec avec des pierres
précieuses incrusté à la place des yeux
bref le projet en ce moment en
développant sur kiss kiss je vous
mettrai à venir dans la description bref
on a parlé tout ça avec les éditeurs
surtout l'éditeur qui est devenu un bon
copain parce que c'est un taré des
énigmes comme nous et il m'a dit mais tu
sais si tu veux ça fait longtemps je
n'ai pas au crédit une énigme tu peux
t'en faire une choqué vas-y banco et
puis moi je parle de son lead ce n'est
pas un placement de produit c'est un
placement de copains ça fait plaisir
vous le savez si vous avez suivi un peu
les stories récemment je reviens de
tourner et j'ai douze heures de décalage
horaire dans la tête extra du coup on va
dire j'ai un demi cerveau donc pour
faire un cerveau complet une fin août
2006 info c'est pourquoi je vais
résoudre cette chasse au trésor avec
loïc loïc quitté en mélange et lettres
ça fait clio loïc et eu la main tendue
que le client est ce que juste sur ta
venue
tu peux faire un générique ah d'accord
le leak génériques
c
je ne veux pas d'une unique la la la la
la la la
voilà mais je veux créer une animation
des sites oui oui on a le droit de
toucher à rien loïc tafer mets pas tes
cheveux dans le chambre pourquoi au
regard des eaux pourquoi on regarde et
pourtant on regarde là pourquoi regarder
parce qu'on se sent juger par les viewer
qui soit fort les dieux mayas les incas
les incas les années que j'avais visité
tulum j'avais un guide et où il parlait
un peu français tu vois c'est maria et
une pression comme cela et comme je vous
ai de mer et toulouse me disait tout
l'eau
c'était très gênant oui mais je
comprends aussi surtout s'il le fait
tout le temps mais vous chie blum
nous avons une instruction l'instruction
qui nous dit a déjà c'est un post it as
a s'est imposée dans machete fabien
arrow post-it masters se régale
attention ne te précipite pas sur les
objets que tu ne connais pas et si bien
les instructions dans l'ordre du coup je
peux me précipiter surtout parce que je
connais ces objets ça c'est une plante
ouais c'est un club ça c'est une
bouteille ça c'était tellement ça c'est
un coffre ok ça c'est une lampe
oui ça c'est une imprimante je trouve
qu'il faut ouvrir les enveloppes en
ouvrir un bon alors cette enveloppe
voilà elle contient d'addiction
peut-être c'est peut-être le but de
cette chasse ce qui évacue sion alors
non pas de cliquer et non et le fils et
n'a rien à voir à ces regards de
l'envelope il ya une feuille que je vais
te laisser découvrir loïc un petit code
a décrit ce qu'on veut bien tout seul
c'est du wings
certaines phrases sous des apparences
anodines peuvent avoir un double sens
par tous ensemble pour un grand tour du
monde
pour ne pas perdre le nord au cours de
ta quête rappelle toi que le diable se
cache dans les détails
tintintin
une fois la clé fin identifiait fait
rempli lesquels suivante cela devrait
permettre de décrypter ce message
ok donc on va chercher une clé une clé
pour avoir scellé truc de cryptage
oui parce que en fait je cherchais une
récurrence il n'y a pas de récurrence
donc ça doit être un visionnaire sait
bien que c'est bien tu le précise pour
ceux qui n'avaient pas d'importance et
pas moi je vais te la fais vigenère
troisième l'angoissé ça bon on parle de
tour du monde donc ça on va servir du
club qui peut être souverain ne sais pas
parce que vous regardiez du jeu on a ici
un petit coffret ce qui s'ouvre lui pour
la pour le moment non évidemment libre
et c'est la clé la clé de faim la
fameuse ici il nous faudra un code à
trois chiffres
ça c'est génial ça je connaissais pas du
tout les bouchons comme ça trop comme ça
a été inventé spécialement pour ça moi
je pense que plus tôt quand tu as dû
binard chez toi qui veux pas que tu es
gamin il tape dedans ou des trucs comme
ça ou alors que tu es vachement radin
donc tu es très radin très ragga alors
un perron mais c'est plus personne peut
voir qu'en plus c'était parce qu'en fait
quand t'es bourré tu te suis un peu du
code et donc du plateau on a la clé qui
est là donc sa 5ème est ce que tu crois
que c'est un vrai qu'un à clé ou si un
cadenas casse tête
le petit format on en a fait des cadenas
avec des fans qui servait à rien mais là
je pense que vraiment il faut trouver
une clé regardant cette vidéo est ce que
tu as fait une blague au rythme d'un
vivarium a tant fait françois pendant
tes pieds des minimoys déjà l'arbre se
soulève moi je trouve que c'est un mini
baobab certaines phrases sous des
apparences anodines peuvent avoir un
double sens on peut être il parle de ses
phrases là où cette phrase là tu vois
partons ensemble pour un grand tour du
monde peut pas perdre le nord pour pas
perdre le nord au cours de ta quête
rappelle toi que c'est le diable se
cache dans les détails
qu'est ce qu'on a ici on le croit qu'ils
ont écrit des choses ici à l'intérieur
au nord de la carte mais le nord le nord
c'est ici peut-être quelque chose
d'aussi en dessous est ce que ça se
dévissent non est-ce que ça ça se
déboîte non tu vois cette théorie est
complètement annulé
un peu que le dire le diable se cache
dans les détails donc dans les détails
de la carte il ya peut-être quelque
chose en fait tu vois bah écoutes je me
mets là dessus peut-être tu peux faire
là on a un diable c'est quoi les détails
des saints je pense que le cas de la
tête de mort c'est pour le diable bas en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
diabolique ici outre ton esprit malinois
tu vas trouver des chaussures la carte
toujours pas parce que tu vois ma maison
d'ici mais un tout petit match zoug
comme ça que tu fais ça sur le dos ça
marche presque une fois tu joues dans
l'océan atlantique moi habitent dans le
secteur en poissons qu'on écoute moi un
cachalot
est-ce que tu connais le mystère de
l'atlantique c'est chez moi c'est pas un
rébus souris tous drapeaux ça me fait
penser à quoi comme prévu c'est vrai nom
ça devrait prendre peut-être en anglais
mouse and flag flag of frog fric va donc
la grenouille donc la pluie dont wells
qu'il pleut beaucoup à dunkerque
à dunkerque le nord le nord tout nous
ramène au nord mystère résolu bravo et
ben ouais super super abonnez vous lire
la description d'un kwassa nous relie au
zinc à tout ça omar bongo en tout mais
notre point de départ où on suit la
piste du nord ou d'aidé et des détails
et on cherche quelque chose sur cette
carte
certaines phrases certaines fois sous
des apparences anodines pour faire
d'avoir un double sens peu délire dans
le sens double à 1 à voir si on n'est
qu'au début et qu'après ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué t'imagines à il
ya des variations dans le texte dont il
ne veut pas mais lui ne veut pas bon de
choses attendez souillé par il est pas
ainsi le sc différents d'un même tous ou
un joint
donc ça voudrait dire que sous des
appâts soudé absout le monde
laissez moi j'en appelle à man pouvoirs
magiques sont terminées elles sont sales
que aussi différents besoins sont grands
un grand sous un grand sous un grand
quelque chose se cache sous un grand se
cache la clé
bon sous un grand nord regarde awards et
là c'est tout petit là mais je vois pas
comment tu vois moi j'aime imaginer le
teint du coup c'est incohérent que le
compteur doit ou sous un grand nord se
cache la clé attendez c'est le grand
nord sait où c'est le groenland en or
c'est l'anagramme de drones on a un
drone dans la réserve
c'est peut-être sous le drone mais il a
gâché et les petits sous de l'or se
cache à lille ces normes
c'est grand lit si on attend on
affaiblit le real ale et la soule il
souligne tout lille l'île de ré ouais
sous l'île de ré et à quoi tu à l'île
d'oléron faut qu'on aille dans l'odéon
on est parti le grand nord c'est où le
grand nord bah pour moi quand tu dire
renoncer l'alaska n'a alors c'est
l'amérique des lacets l'alaska pour tout
le monde sait pas c'est si j'étais genre
aux états unis je suis à jouer dans le
grand nord gr en alaska
moi si j'étais un homme je serai
capitaine même pas tout aucun rapport
je suis fatigué je t'ai demandé de venir
ouais c'est que maintenant métier pour
le mettre plus loin pour voir en fait
mon père a commencé à dire c'est à
partir de 50 ans attend là où valu à la
cuisse le lit jamais direct commencé à
tricher un peu les yeux là et puis à un
moment donné ses bras étaient trop
courts cette chose qui n ont regardé
tout simplement un revers assez nord ben
ouais mais ça doit le tropique du cancer
tropique du cancer un grand grand mais
c'est ça c'est tropique du cancer
moi je les trouvais ben oui c'est moi
qu'il est rude et loïc je pensais
vraiment pas je pense que je vais m'en
aller maintenant parce que ce qu'était
ce qui était génial par contre c'est à
dire tropique du cancer et tu dis mais
bon c'est pas pour ça qu'il poil le bon
nombre de lettres en fait on s'aperçoit
de quoi on s'aperçoit que ce n'est pas
un défi nir que c'est plus simple que ça
donc je te laisse attaquer la suite
qu'est-ce que tu ferais maintenant pour
décrypter ce message et bah je reprends
les lettres qui correspondent
essayons jean-jacques mais ça ça tu as a
annoncé à existe donc par exemple ça je
sais que ça y est on est d'accord je
check et avant que tu commences que tous
les oeufs et la même correspondance
parce que de la com com on a plusieurs
lettres qui sont doublés le but c'est
bien deux fois le clavier etc donc
déclassé gentil quoi le clavier on
l'apport non mais ça va pouvoir nous
aider à trouver l'alphabet complet alors
caché ça c'est 1 h
je mets en tout petit au cas où tu te
trompes je prends pas caché derrière
temps iron bon voilà on voit les jolis
il est dans la bibliothèque
caché derrière ton ligne jean megan
l'aula du bibi bas coût tirent bien de
garder spécial regard des livres bah non
ça c'est rien du tout peut-être en
faisant craquer mais il fera à gad un
autre petit carnet livre tout à fait
c'est ce que je vais faire pour qu'il
soit bien rangé je vais le mettre dans
la description sous forme de liens au
sein d'accor incroyable ça me rappelle
quand tout est d'être là bas alors sa
sensation que c'est un truc qui plaide
passionnés attentes en fait une clé mais
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être loïc une
clé le mot est apparue d'abord sous la
forme play en 1080 du latin clavis clé
look et art à l'origine le mot était
synonyme de play bus clos car la serrure
primitive consisté en un clou which vie
passée dans un anneau la différenciation
sémantique des deux ment en disant est
ce que je pense que si moi je suis
fatigué en ce moment mais si tu dis que
c'est bon on dit là bas ça peut me
semble logique
loïc le logique l'oit son punch et cela
devient logique on apprend tous les
jours
vas-y tout montrer là au soir ça ouvert
le cadenas qui avait une petite pastille
est violette et ça ça nous indique à
temps mais je crois qu'il y avait des
telliers de l'après steve incarné il ya
des petites pastilles pour nous dire
lequel est le bon chemin a utilisé sa
sert a aussi plutôt racistes ainsi a pas
une vraie peur avec laquelle on pourrait
confondre
ok donc a priori nous devons utiliser ce
petit là bien l'entrée est ici un +4 on
peut pas aller plus loin je me dis que
c'est ça ou un ado 6 2 donc il faut
qu'on cherche la sortie
alors avant de trop les sorties il faut
consiste à quoi ça va nous servir ça va
nous servir à c'est probablement une
femme formes géométriques
parce que là ya pas d'autres endroits on
a besoin
deux chiffres parce que qu'est ce qu'il
nous manque ici nous manque une clé pour
ouvrir sa ou alors ça va nous donner 3
chiffres 1 3 chiffres qui permettront
d'ouvrir je pense qu'on n'est plus là
dessus quand même tu voudrais pas
installer le fameux but donc là c'est
tout moment et sur time to shine moi
j'ai shine tout à l'heure avec quand
j'ai trouvé moi au début quand je vois
ça je me dis ok il faut qu'on se fasse
un chemin avec des opérations logiques
ok mais je ne vois pas d'opération
logique dès le début un puisse 4g pas un
5e tour je joue je vois pas de
possibilité de chemin après je me dis
dans ma spontanément j'ai pris un
stabilo ok ok avec ce stabilo je me dis
on pourrait stabilité par exemple toutes
les parenthèses où tous les signes pour
voir un peu ce qu'il reste comme
chiffres dans ces cas là tu vois ce que
je veux dire aux pas vous hein pourquoi
tu voudrais les stabilos t
mais pour voir s'il en ressort un dessin
et si d'ici peut-être on a 1 2 qui
seraient dessinés ou 1,5 ou toi j'en
sais rien en fait tu est le savez notre
quoi l'ailé les signes les plus les
parenthèses les machins comme ça même si
on commence à cette visite aux excès
plus que c'est faux eh ben on ne sera
jamais on le saura jamais on y va on est
déjà les fous on défi fou on n'est pas
des films mais je pense qu'on est
clairement fif ou vous donner une note
sur 10 de notre fille fonderie ouais on
vous attend dans les commentaires et
dans les commentaires vous redonnez
après une note sur 10 pour le mot fille
faudrait jamais tes deux notes en fait
un séparément est ce que tu veux tenter
un truc moi tu n'as jamais fait toi même
tu lances l'accélération le loïc
accélération tante atteinte
[Musique]
attention j'ai peut-être colorier le
négatif l' inverse de ce qu'ils arrivent
fallu colorier dans une vieille de 5 à
10 une poussette ou quelqu'un qui
regarde dans une poubelle
non je fais un petit trou de la chaîne
la chaîne youtube logique je prêtais
montage du coup le parce que là ya que
trois types de symboles utilisés les
plus le multiplier les parenthèses
mais vu le nombre de parenté de plus par
exemple c'est pendant lé content parce
que j'ai plus sur la façon dont plus de
10 ça peut être un hasard mais voilà
sachent qu'il ya trois symboles utilisés
et qu'on cherche 3 chiffres 1 1 devrait
colorier tous les un coloris tous les as
que ça nous changerait quelque chose là
dans la forme
[Musique]
je me dis comme on cherche quand même
trois chiffres mais est ce qu'il ya des
zones qui nous permettraient de voix
mais si l'on me des plus et des moins
en fait on va juste faire les plus et
les multiplier un plus un plus un ça
fait trop un plus
11 x 11 1 thermale comme y'a pas de plus
entre temps un devant une parenthèse le
parenthèse multiplicatrice donc là
j'étais un toit c'est ce multiplicateur
sur les salaires enfin est ce que est ce
qu'on a fait on a fait un chemin
contondant lors du chemin
on a fait un chemin bravo loïc vous
m'impressionnez je rejoins on refait tu
me dicte mes malheurs compte un plus un
plus un
[Musique]
ça fait cinquante plus de ça fait
cinquante deux mois qu'est ouais donc
pour l'instant tab on soit 112 peut-être
l'aider centimes et dessins thing ne
compte pas connu pour des raisons
évidentes sécurité nationale on l'a dit
combien 300 on à 10 312 312 mais est ce
qu on a rajouté les de la faim et qui ça
fait donc 314 tiens tiens tiens est ce
que ça ne rappellerai pas quelque chose
toi bien garde un sac d'os de 6 par
exemple
pis le poil [ __ ] mais c'est incroyable
tout est lié alors oui qu'est ce que
vous pouvez nous lire ce texte
malicieusement bien sûr des cours qui
elles sont confirmées les dans l'ordre
elle te permettront de trouver un
symbole non tu es proche c'était un peu
ma mission ok ça faisait un peu
découlent les fiches haut de ta région
la plus australe dans la rose 1 / 6 1 6e
2/5 trois quarts le presque point commun
de fabien et loïc absente chez perec la
tête de l'escargot la plus australe dans
la redon soit tu dirais que c'est le sud
le sud
la rose comme ça donc à plus australe
dans la rose css presque point commun de
fabien et loïc ça c'est drôle que nous
sommes c'est drôle mais que c'est dur
heureusement fabien et le presque point
commun passé le i way avec le point de
jeu parce que moi j'ai un traitement et
oignies un 6e - de 5e - trois quarts ça
fait donc le fcp en quelques mois je
pensais pas bah en fait ça nous fait 7 7
parce que a ici ça fait 7 5 et 2 ap 7 et
4 et 3 ça fait 7
donc ça nous fait 777 partie relations
je le mets de côté au cas où je mets de
côté
l'absence cerexhe et il n'a pas écrit un
bouquin je ressens
une lettre il sent que c'est un truc ça
me parle je crois que c'est le premier
bouquin qui a été fait comme ça avec une
contrainte 2e manche n'y a pas un seul e
dans le roman c'est ça ouais c'est bien
celui des magnifiques leur égard donc on
se met eux voyaient pas sauter ce nom
celui-là on est l'absence j'espérais que
c'est le et la tête de l'escargot
qu'est-ce qui est sur la tête de
l'escargot un thé t'as faim tu es la
tête de l'esclavagé parce que ça ça fait
tige
alors je commence déjà à chercher le mot
potentiels afin de trouver la tête de
l'escargot bas ou des à priori c'est la
première lettre
donc l aile non non ça c'est comme un
ours sais pas selon certaines voix
l'avion madame 7 mai s'explique j'ai
quelques fautes qui traînent des feux de
rennes dans les vidéos un avion un avion
est la veille au y s g 10e eu viol mais
tant que ça devrait l'être dans
l'ordinateur les 30000 euros 6 millions
n'est pas ton joue dans le siège sous
son siège son siège
non il peut suivre et c'est l'anagramme
de siagi ya rien loïc regarde sur le bia
ikea 22100 cette âme c'est encore une
histoire de calcul c'est assez chiant
attendait c'était pas si les gens mais
tu veux que je sois quoi qu'est ce que
ça pourrait faire en vrai le siège toi
alors c'est vrai à l'époque je ne sais
pas d'où ça vient à 7 7 7 21
comme c'est dit comme le ct récurrents
tu vois pour commencer c'est quoi le g10
21 c'est quoi ces no24 lettres dans
l'alphabet dans 26 des cas je sais je
suis décalé et oui j'aurais tous 87 dans
23 pour w 22 pour vais donc vater tcu
cheveux ses propos c'est parce que ça
m'arrange pas trop d'avoir un huissier -
lui suit lui
trois sets 21 joli joli joli
si tu arrives en fait les phases d'un
des plus quoi les traces d'un dé à jouer
j'en ai pas mais imagine ça c'est un des
moteurs
attends je vais faire apparaître un
départ la force de ma pensée ont elles
bougent pas ko fait partie de mes
pouvoirs donc les phases d'un délai face
opposée d'un dea sont toujours égale à 7
ok donc là on a un à côté donc le 6 de
l'autre on a le 3 d'un côté donc le
cadre de l'autre on a le sac d'un côté
donc le 2 de l'autre ok c'est vrai ça
fun fact et du coup si je fais ça ça
tourne et c'est un peu style et les gens
n'aiment pas la voiture donc à des à des
indes et on pourrait dire que c'est la
lettre d par exemple tu vois on pourrait
dire aussi on essaye toutes les lettres
de l'alphabet jusqu'aux canaries à
quelque chose et là d'un coup et moi
personnellement j'ai une idée très le
mot le mot qui était l'idée mais à quoi
ça nous amène basse alors j'en sais rien
à te permettront de trouver un symbole
dont tu es proche le symbole de l'idée
symbole de l'idc sur 1 en poule et une
ampoule donc sur mon ampoule qui en plus
est une ampoule qui ne fait pas de
chaufferie en plus ça voilà oui alors
fleurir en poule peut-être aussi parce
que l'idée sacékripa avec un s et qu'on
a fait que quand même il est de plus à
exploiter
on a dit des 1 e 1 e s je peux chanter
mais bouger
sid
si siné ça va être des eaux chlorées
alain mais il ya au pluriel jeu parce
qu'elle est le symbole des idéaux clos
riels qui seraient près de moi ça c'est
pas un symbole à part les cerveaux c est
ce que j'ai un cerveau près de moi ce
côté là de quoi ça me fait un dièse diaz
bien sûr diaz hashtags et diaz en
français c'est sûr que c'est beau à voir
ça peut pas être un hasard la saf et
diez alors face à cette vieillesse oui
moi je suis connu pour deux choses mon
humour est mon sens de l'observation
quel traitement que le sens de
l'observation vraiment top
amenez moi ma deuxième paire de lunettes
voilà ok on est partis kasparov chat ou
non attends attends toi là tu entends
peut-être il faut garder ta tête tu as
trois têtes rasées regarde on vient
d'envoyer avec de la direction dans
l'ordre non sérieusement vraiment c'est
fou ça alors il m'est à regarder au fait
si dans l'idée il n'y avait pas un truc
mairie fait dans le dr armand à
l'intérieur gagne clés au mcg a envisagé
de passe à ne pas servir de boîte à clé
il ya un trousseau et de troussel et
c'est là qu'est ce que ça va c'est ça
bref un diamant oui mais il y avait un
truc en plus exclus les couleurs souvent
pour obtenir un indice hockey celle de
la couverture du livre du moment bon
jaune celle de celui qui est en rage
rouge rouge celle de celles dont l'aïeul
se fait dévorer pomme je bois croissance
moyenne ceux préférant attendre il
reviendra à celle entre le dépôt les
deux précédentes cette 1ère rencontre
dans l'inconnu celle d'une flore un peu
cucul excuse pas le rose est ce que ces
qq loseless muespach romantique
finalement une route à part ça peut être
la violette aussi un calcul à violer tu
que c'est pas une expérience et la
praline qu'est cucul la praline guen
mais après ça dépend pour certains
orange ses pralines d'accord mais simon
schempp aller une praline c'est quoi
pour eux elle arrange mais aurenche et
quoi c'est aline et la dernière de l'arc
l'arc ces ententes hier c'est la lutte
conte le son cancer dans cet arc en ciel
avec l'arc en ciel donc bible genre
d'annoncé les rouges on se faire que
celle qui est en rage ce n'était pas
pour nous 2 0
aucun orage d'une instruction qui
figurent dans l'avis utilise avec la
ficelle
tiens tu vois j'ai dit que la ficelle
desservirait pour explorer la forêt
ouais celle de la couverture du livre du
moment on peut se les voir sur un jeu
requiert que c'est le jaune c'est lui
qui est en rage on a déduit que c'était
rouge mais peut-être que tu mets
peut-être que c'est pas rouge et que
rouge correspond à la dernière dans
l'arc la dernière dollar pour moi ces
rôles celle de se débloquer pour les
couleurs derrière foncia qui soit le
moyen de mots terribles horribles genre
violet et indigo bleu orange en a envie
vert jaune orange rouge pour moi ici on
est sur le rouge en rage je suis vert de
rage
on a peur ou journée et pourquoi je t'ai
fait parce que dans et dans inside out
le film de pixar je suis cuit tout en
nerfs et la colère il est rouge
ouais mais c'est pas la bonne expression
pour ange riez bleu gris et violet gris
et rose grille et blanc grillé et celle
d'une fleur un peu seul sur le contour
des yeux
la grand mère jeanine et andré de reuil
à le seul petit chaperon rouge jolie
laguiole en mer rouge il est là alors
ouattara
trois trucs donc le rouge est là donc ça
s'est toujours pas le rouge en fait un
du coup entre le vert et le rouge
il ya le jaune et le orange dont classe
pour moi c'est le orange puisque le
jaune on l'a déjà tapé ok donc là mais
alors souvent de griller à au feu au feu
des fois tu passes orange la seconde
rija punis non nous et ben non tu y en a
donc on à jaune vert rouge orange nous
en manque deux celle d'une fleur un peu
cucul qu en fait si monde c'est la
dernière de la du coup il me parle pas
moi je me dis bleu parce que c'est la
dernière de l'arc en ciel qu'on n'a pas
utilisée
si tu vois que la salle et ça pourrait
clore les si tu vois leurs conseils dans
environ une semaine violet ici pour voir
ce que je pensais au début pour voir
fleur bleue je te tue la bleue est
franchement ce qu'on peut enlever le
bleu bleu violet il nous resterait rose
et blanc ouais alors
[Musique]
identifie d'anti s'y identifient
l'intrus identifie intrus c'est à foison
ça c'était dedans ça ouais donc l'intrus
je compris à mes attentes les noms mais
ce n'est pas des frères l'intrus c'est
la seule qui est pareillement table mais
tout à l'heure il est écrit li
l'instruction qui figura inquiétudes et
ça si on la fait trop chaud
elle a way et toi tu penses qu'à au
moins tous aller dans la forêt avec sa
d'un lapin il va gars je vois vous aimez
vous avez un [ __ ] [ __ ] c'est rapide
rect dirais que j'ai senti un truc ça a
fait clic on dirait une petite clé place
de ces conteneurs pêche mais c'est un
truc coucou toutefois alors qu'on met on
a regardé le baobab tout à l'heure on
n'a rien trouvé
ok c'est l'heure
cette voie de la place adjudant adjudant
copains et c'est vraiment
si fou fou l'aliénation du trésor ils
sont au pied it's time to open
le hic j'enfonce les clés de ma série
non non c'est ce que je dis là
l'impression que tel pouces je suis
débloqué au niveau du déblocage jeu peu
après avoir ce qu'elle l'oeuvre dans
l'eau y croquer ce comme dans comme un
peu le fait que je ne te regarde pas
d'accord et il ya que les viewer qui
voient ça a l'air assez incroyable je
vois qu'il ya une histoire de maya et de
poing pantone
je crois vraiment que j'ai entendu un
mot quand j'ai ouvert ferment les yeux
ou tulum tout ton nom c'est reparti mon
gars et je croyais que c'était fini - ok
ça c'est pas un truc à ultraviolets ça a
dit fabien oui je crois que quelqu'un te
veut du mal les abonnés regardent sur
ton coeur talents de comédien incroyable
bien joué
fabien n'ya pas de temps dont 1,6 avec
ses skis paul camp du type tu lis tu es
prêt à te la mettre à te lancer lancé
l'engin à la recherche de l'or ah oui ça
c'est la lettre ouverte c'est une des
lettres qui te manquer le à arles en or
lors sa mère lors deux chiffres en panne
et non pas de la piste et non pas de se
dire je fais bien tu es prête c'est la
recherche de noms lors de ses six panne
de l'ordre de sipan sipan c'est
l'espérance ban
et ben si pomme si c'est sûrement le
résultat de cette enveloppe mon bon ami
oh oh c'est un petit ils viennent à jo
ça c'est ce qu'on m'avait parlé
d'émeraude on avait parlé de statut non
mais oui c'est vrai alors c'est pas pour
cette énigme c'est pour la nouvelle
chasse au trésor qui lance lors de sipan
donc c'est un livre que vous pouvez
trouver il ya un lancement sur kiss kiss
bang bang
c'est une énigme une aile une chasse une
aventure où il n'y a pas forcément
besoin de bouger de chez soi un petit
peu comme eux comme celui que moi
j'avais fait l'année dernière
sauf que là voilà il n'y a pas dit
diamants il ya cette statuette en or qui
a été fabriqué traditionnellement au
pérou exprès pour les besoins de ce gala
avec des urnes les mots rôti une belle
bêtise et surtout on s'en fout en fait
du trésor diack
c'est toujours un truc très motivant
mais c'est pas ce qui doit te motiver à
faire la chasse à on est même un c'est
aussi aussi le délire de faire ce genre
de chasse je vais pas vous la spoil vous
avez un lien dans la description pour la
découvrir
on va se montrer ce petit à petit il vit
sur la fin de la vidéo
merci aux éditions du trésor de m'avoir
organisé cette chasse a vraiment c'était
très cool de percer avec loïc et je les
aime beaucoup j'adore leur travail
depuis 2010 est je vous parle de ses pas
pour rien allez allez voir ça allait
voir le lien de la description encore
une fois ne croyez pas que c'est un
placement de produit je ne touche rien à
part ce plaisir d'avoir fait cette vidéo
avec toi mon cher loïc ça m'a fait
plaisir aux lois une vidéo avec vous et
que vous pouvez retrouver sur sur de 0,6
gratuit que vous pouvez retrouver sur
son instagram
il a passé les dix cas c'est incroyable
c'est à dire sans rien [ __ ] un état
grave elle a passé les dix mille vous
avez le lien de son instinct dans la
description vous avez également la
possibilité de laisser un pouce bleu à
cette vidéo pouces bleus qui vous êtes
suspect à proscrire et riz blé et champs
ces tendances lg amour et amour pendant
huit jours à moins denses et 5 passes et
5 c à vous a été réduit à faire et que
toi tu as tendance à minimiser les
choses genre le nombre de lettres de
l'alphabet c'est par pouce en l'air sur
cette vidéo à bonoua cette chaîne j'ai
oublié de dire durant la vidéo mais
abonnés un bonheur c'est une chose qu'on
apprécie longuement pour regarder les
nouvelles vidéos et vous pouvez activer
la cloche lien dans la description pour
l'or de sipan allez voir ça juste choqué
vous n'êtes pas obligé de l'acheter mais
checker regarder ce que c'est c'est très
cool et moi je vous dis à très bientôt
ciao ne bougent pas ils vont voir qu'on
a peur et l eau
mais là